tout
main dans la main et il dans les
quartiers de beyrouth du quartier que
certaines ne fréquente d'ordinaire pas
du tout ne faisons qu'un chantier mère
chrétienne et musulmane
en réaction aux violences
interconfessionnelles qui se sont
invités dans les manifestations
antigouvernementales la semaine dernière
le pen pour nous le pas pour eux on va
vivre et ils vont vivre touche de charme
des libanais la nationalité célibat
n'est pas d'autres
moi j'évite la guerre les choix sont 15
[Applaudissements]
malgré les récentes tensions voilà bien
le caractère inédit des manifestations
qui déferle dans les rues libanaise
depuis le 17 octobre dernier dans un
pays où tout de la représentation
parlement aux emplois dans la fonction
publique en passant par une ministère
est calculé et partager sur la base des
18 confessions religieuses reconnues en
colère du peuple se moque des divisions
sectaires pour la première fois seeds of
movement deux équipes
dans le nord du pays et à tripoli
deuxième ville en importance au liban la
place centrale est devenu un lieu de
rencontres familiales incroyable que ce
soit maintenant j'arrive pas à croire
même par son temps entre paris et
tripoli sa ville natale
l'ingénieur ne croyait plus que les
choses pouvaient changer il a
l'impression d'assister à un miracle on
peut pas revenir en arrière
rien ne sera comme avant rien puisque
tout la première fois les gens sont mis
en contact
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui sont
arrivés là on a vu pendant ces quarante
jours les saumures à tripoli pour la
première fois de leur vie les croyances
et plein de salafistes
alors ils ont été étonnés il tony parce
que l'ambiance ici est résolument à la
faire
ahmed fait partie des gardiens de
tripoli groupe citoyen bénévole qui a
pris en charge la sécurité de la ville à
la triste réputation d'être un terreau
fertile pour le groupe terroriste
jeunesse ici très largement pauvre
condamnés au chômage elle a toutes les
raisons de se révolter
si les libanais peuvent revendiquer
aujourd'hui comme victoire de s'être
reconnu chez l'autre il ne fait aucun
doute que c'est l'économie désastreuse
qui a mis le feu aux poudres
là près de 50 jours les indicateurs
disent qu' on est en récession
ça c'est clair mais je pense qu'on est
entré plus dans un cycle de dépression
plutôt que de récession une dépression
c'est une récession mais qui est plus
aiguë et plus prolongé dans le temps
je ne sais même pas qu'est ce qui va
nous faire sortir de cette situation
dans laquelle on se trouve surtout que
les conditions politiques et même
sécuritaire ne sont pas à la hauteur
depuis plusieurs mois le dollar
américain la devise reine du temps se
fait rare les banques non plus elle ne
les distribuent plus qu'au compte
gouttes ce qui suscite la hargne des
libanais privés de leur économie qui
prennent les banques pour cible
officiellement le dollar se maintient à
quelques 1500 livres libanaises et sur
le marché noir
la valeur du dollar peut fluctuer de 30
à 40 % en une seule journée
ça fait le bonheur des spéculateurs
comme arsène mais pas aujourd'hui
cette crise économique porte un coup
presque fatal au portefeuille déjà
meurtrie des libanais plus du quart
d'entre eux vivent sous le seuil de la
pauvreté le taux de chômage frôle les
50%
l'inflation est galopante autour de 35%
et ceux qui ont la chance de travailler
voient leurs revenus amputés gustaf
accumule les diplômes de gestion et les
emplois pour arriver à soutenir sa mère
et sa soeur lourdement handicapés ils
occupent deux postes d'enseignants et
travaille dans une boutique de vêtements
au cours du dernier mois à ses heures de
travail ont été réduites tout comme son
salaire dans l'après steve bruce baïkal
et christiane motrice d'un service
client nie toutes jambes ce rapport
d'expert en douane jaguar personnes
développent
au plus fort des manifestations mustapha
descendez tous les jours dans la rue un
pervers et l'espoir qu'il a ressenti en
foulant le pavé pendant un mois
s'estompent les affrontements violents
de la dernière semaine
l'ue entend lever le but de revendiquer
30 au kiosque à dove of protesters la
colère de la rue libanaise a bien eu
raison du premier ministre saad hariri
qui a fini par démissionner une victoire
qui ne satisfait pas les citoyens qui
continue de demander le départ de
l'ensemble de la classe politique
accusée d'avoir pillé le pays sans
accomplir quoi que ce soit les
dirigeants la plupart héritier d'une
longue dynastie politique s'accroche et
espère gagner du temps
trente ans après la fin de la guerre
civile les libanais paraissait encore
billère immunisés au changement les y
semble aujourd'hui s'être découvert une
maturité citoyenne dans ce ras-le-bol
généralisé qu'ils expriment
curité qui permet aux mouvements de
révolte populaires de résister à
l'épuisement un mouvement sans tête
d'affiche ce qui est peut être à propos
parce que ce n'est pas un dirigeant un
homme fort que la rue veut faire dégager
et tout un ordre politique
[Musique]